From hashtags to vigils, the world continues
to mourn the victims of the Paris attacks.
But some responses have been a bit...
misguided.
Here are 3 reactions you should
think twice about.
Roughly half of U.S. governors are vowing
to close their states to Syrian refugees
following the Paris attacks.
This, despite the fact that it remains unclear
if any of the attackers were refugees.
What we do know is that the Syrian refugees
are fleeing the same violence that
devastated Paris.
As President Obama said:
"It is very important that
we do not close our hearts to
these victims
of such violence
and somehow start equating the issue of
refugees with the issue of terrorism."
Even though the majority of all ISIS victims are
Muslim and the majority of all Muslims
don't support ISIS, over the weekend we
saw a backlash against Muslims.
Right-wing protesters stormed a vigil for
the victims, screaming "expel Islamists," and
throwing firecrackers. But they were
ultimately chased away by hundreds of
people yelling, "Go away fascist."
And in the past few days, we've seen even
more examples of ant-muslim sentiment.
In Scotland, an Islamic cultural center
was firebombed.
In Canada, a mosque was set on fire and
a Muslim woman who was picking up her
kids from school was assaulted by two men
while they yelled anti-Muslim profanities at
her.
The media has also perpetuated the sentiment
that Muslims-as a whole- should
be held accountable for the attacks, like these
CNN hosts berating a spokesperson
for an anti-Islamophobia group in France.
And here in the U.S. you've got presidential
candidate Donald Trump who said he'd
monitor mosques and possibly even
shut them down.
Many pundits used the attacks to push the
line that there's a global war between Islam
and the West.
Fox News presenter Andrea Tantaros said
President Obama is being delusional when
he said "Muslims and Christians are not at war."
The reaction to the Paris attack was global.
World leaders rushed to issue statements,
monuments around the world lit up in the
French colors, and people expressed their
sadness and solidarity on social media.
Facebook let you put up a French flag on
your profile picture with one click, and
turned on Safety Check - a service that lets
users tell their friends that they're okay.
The solidarity has been heartening, but none of
that happened when the same
group killed 43 people in Lebanon the day
before Paris, or when they killed 97 in
Turkey a few weeks earlier.
Frequent  ISIS attacks in Syria and Iraq rarely
ellicit the same type of international
reaction Paris got.
Maybe the disproportionate coverage is
because these things aren't expected to
happen in European or North American cities.
But that doesn't make the suffering in
Beirut or elsewhere any less real.
Downplaying that suffering is what helps
misguided reactions against refugees and
entire religious communities to spread.